apex legends universe is the same as
that of titanfall
and their new tie-in hero valkyrie only
brings many of us a stronger desire
or dare i say need for a titanfall 3.
last time we discussed titanfall 2 i
asked what you would want in a titanfall
3
so here are our favorites and somebody
please send this to respawn and get them
on it
thanks titanfall 2 has an
extraordinarily good single player
campaign
the writing and characters were
surprisingly strong
and if you didn't feel a connection to
bt by the end i think you might actually
be a monster
so it's no surprise that the top request
by dennis nick was a return of matthew
mercer
who voiced the main protagonist jack
cooper not only with this being the
return of cooper and getting to see what
exploits he's currently up to
but also we hopefully see a return of
while titanfall 2 had an amazing
multiplayer experience
there are some areas that were changed
from titanfall 1 which
well would be nice to see brought back
one of these was the gen 10 system in
multiplayer
which requires players to actually vary
their loadouts
and play style in order to rank up and
elvivirk says it best
people forget how amazing the gen 10
system was in titanfall 1
forcing players to use every weapon and
ability got you out of your comfort zone
and kept the game
fresh frankly it's easy to discover a
weapon you love
master it and just stick to it change is
scary
but any reason to be brought out of your
comfort zone can be rewarding
it not only meant that you had to become
a better player to earn ranks but learn
how to fight other players doing the
same thing
so this would be a very welcome return
another common request from titanfall 1
was to bring back custom voices
and similarly titan customization
titanfall 2 lets you customize your
pilot
but there's something lost when you
can't personalize your titan
as jello bob puts it having titan ai
scream at mere russian
just hits different that too
that too
hammering this point down further hafi
felski brings up mechwarrior 2
where customizing your mech was a bit of
a balancing act
you had both weight and power limits
meaning you actually had to pretty
strongly consider each thing you were
equipping onto your mac
if the customization of your chassis
armor rating battery slots and
secondary weapons was based on weight
and power limits it would allow for
players to get
super creative with their loadouts maybe
someone wants to have a scorch but
sacrifice their secondary weapon for a
jetpack
maybe a ronin but with an extra battery
slot that allows them to traverse the
map even faster
maybe an atlas that can carry multiple
secondary weapons by sacrificing speed
the potential amount of depth here is
fantastic and to counter the idea that
this would be too nitty-gritty for new
players who just want to pick up a game
and play
i think if general good builds were
automatically prepared for players to
choose
this could easily make the game
accessible for someone who wants that
but also allow for amazing customization
this also just makes common sense with
the lore of titanfall
the militia is supposed to be a far more
hard scrabble group than the imc
with far fewer resources and it never
quite made sense they had the same clean
slash well put together titans
one thing that makes titanfall 2 stand
out from other fps games
is its incredible movement you'll find
yourself running along walls
sliding and bunny hopping around to
avoid bullets while blasting at your
enemies
and one amazing addition to titanfall 2
was its grappling hook
which allows players to spend even more
time off the ground
it was maybe even too good and often a
default pick
meaning players didn't feel free to mess
with other abilities
as such roland suggests that titanfall 3
should either make the grappling hook a
permanent passive ability to help
increase
movement speed or perhaps give players 2
ability slots
that way you can always equip a
grappling hook which you should
or hey it would provide even more
customization which is always a good
thing
when balanced properly and to these
points we couldn't agree more
back once again to titanfall 1 more
first person titan action
what i mean is while titanfall 2
featured absolutely
sick executions players were
automatically taken to a third-person
camera where you get to witness the
glory and spectacle of it
chagan 316 suggests that these should
instead take place entirely in the first
person
as it made executions terrifying and
really cool in the original titanfall
similarly amazon wants first person
titan entries back
once again titanfall 2 reversed to
showing these in the third person
however titanfall 1 had a slick
animation showing the titan grab you and
throw you into its cockpit as you watch
the display slowly turn on
this only added to the immersion and
would definitely be a welcome return for
a titanfall 3.
to that point viper suggests more pilot
customization in general
for example being able to use the phase
shift pilot skin with the cloak ability
or like custom skins in general kind of
like halo
and maybe the mix and match system for
titans and titanfall 1.
granted part of the reason these skins
are specific is it gives players an easy
way to
quickly identify their opponent's stats
at a glance but if we're going to fully
bulk up customization
and say add two slots then at that point
it would nullify the visual aid and
wait a second viper didn't i
kill you
fresh frixie 2358 suggests new modes of
gameplay such as a co-op campaign
similar to portal 2
when frontier defense was added to
titanfall 2 it definitely added more
replayability
and personally i think it's hard to deny
just how much fun a well-crafted co-op
game
with friends can be and while i
absolutely love both the single player
and multiplayer of titanfall 2
something just hits different when it's
you and your buddies against a computer
debited hit us with a whole slew of
suggestions while i'll put all of them
on screen right here for all of you to
read and debate if you like
one that i'm going to point out that i
haven't mentioned earlier is a ranked
playlist as david suggests it would
simply bring more of a competitive scene
to titanfall and make the game more
enjoyable for hardcore gamers
and i think that's a great point while
there's always the issue of new players
being stopped in a long running
multiplayer game
therefore not wanting to play i do think
finding ways to get players rankings and
matching them that way is always a
fantastic addition
it gives people added incentive to play
it helps give more skilled players a
lobby where they won't be
as focused on obliterating new people
and frankly
anything that adds to the longevity of a
multiplayer game is definitely a big
plus
playing 476 lucky once a longer
single-player campaign in titanfall 3.
i'm of the opinion that titanfall 2 solo
campaign was perfect
it didn't outstate its welcome and
everything lasted just the right amount
of time
but honestly it was also so good that i
wanted more
so anything that means more single
player campaign i
am all for at this point apex legends in
titanfall's worlds are one in the same
characters and references to titanfall 2
are abound in apex legends
lucky cat suggests that if there's ever
a titanfall 3 we should see references
or even usage of apex legends characters
and
why not it would definitely help bring
in new players who are already fans of
apex legends
and the worlds are already combined so
it's not exactly a stretch
we suggested in the previous video that
would be great to see more types of
escapes
the drop ship is a genius way to let the
losing team still have some kind of win
so it'd be even better to have a few
different scenarios
all in middle 64 agrees with this and
thinks there's a lot of potential for
different ideas that could integrate
with the particulars of a map
another suggestion we had was to make
you feel bad about grunt farming
titanfall 2 has them specifically if
you're a titan stop
fighting and beg for you not to crush
them tartepal suggests that it would be
nice if they disappeared or something to
that extent if you chose to spare them
what do you think finally coming back to
the single player
one thing i personally want to see is
more action blocks used with an
exploration of dynamic and fun new
gameplay beats
in a gdc panel designer subi talked
about how the team experimented with
what they referred to as action blocks
where they quickly come up with gameplay
styles and beats and
iterate on the best of these this is how
they created such a fantastic first
person campaign
and i'm sure if the same creative team
got together again they could jam out
even more incredible ideas
and there were incredible maps in single
player where pilots were forced to
contend with the moving stage
like the factory how cool would it be to
see this incorporated into the
multiplayer
where you're not only contending with
the enemy but also quickly adapting your
movement to just for an ever-changing
stage
what ideas do you agree with or hey
strongly disagree with
everyone has different tastes so i'd
love to hear your thoughts let's keep
dreaming respawn can count to three
better than valve
and keep letting me know what you hope
to see in a titanfall 3
and i'll see you guys next time
you